knock at the cabin is M Night
shyamalan's second R rated movie and boy
does it deliver they were working with
real weapons and fight scenes the cabins
were built from scratch creepy dolls
were being dragged across the floor and
there's a chilling explanation for all
of the erratic close-up shots watch but
first I got a shout out to Dave Bautista
he really wanted one day of relaxation
because every other day he was just
going through the ringer I mean after
watching the movie I can see why he said
this was the most challenging role he's
ever done but he also said it's the role
he's waited for for his entire career
because he's an ex-wrestler Dave always
gets Typecast as you know the action
hero guy who doesn't really talk he says
he's spoken more in knock at the cabin
than he has in his entire career this
was his way of proving himself as a
serious actor it's really to
to prove myself is to prove my worth
especially with that final scene
you know you know oh and as brutal as it
may have been to watch the story behind
behind Dave's demise is pretty hilarious
shoot the scene that day because the
tone is very dark and he was just in a
great mood it also didn't help that the
weather was beautiful how are you
supposed to be somber on a sunny day hey
and the fact that they needed a bit of
an overcast to shoot the scene well they
ended up having to wait anyway and that
waiting went on and on and on by the
time the clouds rolled in Dave decides
he's not doing the scene anymore
honestly I can't blame him for wanting
to stay alive that day there's also
another reason Dave didn't want to do
his intense scene that day bro was
spiraling hard I was like sure you got
an eagle bro he hated watching himself
on dailies and even though the work is
done now he still looks back and wishes
he'd done some things differently never
really satisfied and I want to grow as
an actor I see room Improvement luckily
while shooting he didn't have a ton of
time to dwell on it because they were on
such a tight schedule he says all the
cabin scenes were like one long drawn
out shot but it wasn't just weather in
lighting that were quality controlled
take a look at all those tasks Dave
Bautista has did you notice which one
suddenly disappeared when he was on
camera and Knight said
litter doesn't seem like the type of guy
who would have rock star on his knuckles
every other tattoo you see on Leonard is
an aspect of Dave but they had to switch
up the knuckles to really match
Leonard's persona it's clear why Dave
Bautista has rock star on his knuckles
gotta show up in style everywhere right
even to the 7am Zumba class yep you
heard that right the party bus was not
on route to a typical kegger but to M
Night shyamalan's wife's Zumba class
okay picture this the entire knock at
the cabin cast getting on a party bus at
5am to catch a Zuma class after filming
fight scenes all night do you Zumba I
mean I'd probably go for it in this case
but 7am it's a bit questionable
something else questionable the way
those actors were handling weapons
luckily they were playing characters who
weren't experts so they could afford to
look a little uncomfortable with them
they were given two versions of each one
that was real and it was super heavy the
other one was a fake that was used for
when they were swinging at each other's
heads well there weren't any Mix-Ups
there they worked with stunt coordinator
Manny Saverio for a full week just
learning how to swing them and when they
weren't swinging weapons they were
mostly just trying to hang out by the
lake okay well not everyone just
Jonathan Groff and Ben Aldridge they hit
it off so well that they'd often get in
trouble on set night was quoted actually
saying at some point I was like there's
nothing else you could say to each other
you've said everything stop talking to
each other
they had a lot in common like the fact
that they both grew up on farms and
their grandfathers were both weirdly
ministers how Niche The Vibes on set
between them were always good which was
helpful because they spent a lot of time
together in close quarters speaking of
this movie was filmed in not one but two
cabins built from scratch anyone know if
they're available on Airbnb JK anyways
one of the cabins was built on location
South Jersey the same area where the
bodies were dumped in The Sopranos
creepy much New Jersey had passed this
film tax credit law to attract more
Studios to the state and Money Talks so
this movie was just one of 45 movies
being made in the States since then the
second cabin was built in a warehouse so
the crew could actually control all the
technical elements like weather and
lighting okay so the way things are done
on movie sets is honestly just weird
Kristen Cooley who plays Wen was pretty
surprised by all of it they were
dragging this like white all and it had
nothing on it and they were dragging
across the floor to make that blood
track this was her first feature film so
she didn't know what to expect but
definitely not the use of a doll to make
tracks on the floor I mean that could
just be M Night shyamalan's quirky
directing style though have you seen
many of night's movies if you're
obsessed like me you'll know that his
camera angles are kind of all over the
place he says he does this to convey
emotion without having to explain it
narratively he deserves it and we love
it the close-up shots for example
there's a lot of close-ups because
they're at a nine from almost go the
close-ups represent Panic the
protagonist is laser focused trying to
figure out if they're in danger the wide
shots are used to convey scattered
thoughts I might be talking to you but
I'm thinking about how to get out and I
could do that in a wide shot he is
pretty particular when it comes to the
language of Cinema and what that can
convey the only time he really gets to
have fun with it is when he's the one on
camera oh and yet another thing he does
appearing in his own movies knock at the
cabin is no different but it was
actually incredibly difficult to find a
way to actually fit it into the story's
narrative the rest of the cast also had
no idea where he would insert himself
into the movie if you don't know it's a
commercial where Knight is selling an
air fryer every time the cast would look
at the TV on set it was actually just a
green screen so nobody knew what was
going to be on it Knight pitched the
idea to the crew and it ended up being
one of the first scenes they shot and
it's hilarious definitely worth string
for the book for this one and also if
you haven't read this book it's a must
read when M Night Shyamalan basically
got wrapped up in it one day he
literally thought I want to make this a
movie and direct it and everyone around
him was like hell yeah please we love to
see it so now we have knock at the cabin
as he wrote it he fell in love with it
and we decided let's let's go make it
the book is called the cabin at the End
of the World by Paul Tremblay and M
Night Shyamalan created his own story
from the book hand-picking all of these
actors he was described as demanding
challenging and kind of a perfectionist
but in a good way you can never really
sit back and relax even if you're in a
scene you just sat a chair knock at the
cabin takes a sharp turn away from the
original narrative and creates an
endori let's
litter and a touch of Comedy this film
is carving a totally new path for
contained horror movies what was your
favorite scene let us know down in the
comments